all right so Joe Biden he is desperate
to send more of your money to Ukraine
we've sent nearly what 80 some odd
billion dollars uh that he's apparently
willing to even trade Republicans almost
anything for it including even Trump era
immigration policies now Biden is now
reportedly considering bringing back
title 42 or a program like that that
would allow border patrol to expel
illegals on the spot now naturally
Democrats they're not happy calling the
idea a non-starter shameful cruel
irresponsible responsible anyway here
with reaction is the Democratic senator
from West Virginia Joe Mansion is with
US senator we've had over 8 million
according to estimates illegal
immigrants come in this country under
Joe Biden uh hundreds from Iran hundreds
from Syria thousands from Egypt
thousands from Afghanistan 12,000 from
Russia and over 20 some odd thousand
from China um I am 100% certain that we
probably have because those borders have
been wide open terrorist cells now in
this country do you agree with
me I'm as concerned and scared as you
are Sean I've truly been saying this all
along our borders are a mess and you
know to say that it's not and for any
Democrat or anybody to say that it's not
in jeopardy right now we have to close
our borders down we've got to control
the borders and we have to change
basically the asylum definition of what
it takes to get in our country we want
to make sure that people can still come
that are in desperate need the legal way
but not the way they're coming illegally
now and that has to stop so I believe
that uh that you're going to see some
changes being made here very quickly and
I think it's more than appropriate to do
it let me ask you you said you were
taking a two-month tour beginning in
January uh to test the appetite for
national movement there's been a lot of
talk about the No Labels party and
whether or not they would consider
running as a third party in the
presidential election uh is this twomon
tour part of a tour for you yourself are
you considering would you consider
running on a No Labels party for
president in 2024 well Sean first let me
just say I'll never be a spoiler I will
never be a spoiler trying to throw the
race one way or the other if it would be
advantage or disadvantage that's not who
I am if I get into a race I get into it
to win but basically going around people
feel homeless right now they've been
pushed to the extremes both parties have
gone to the extremes the Democrat and
Republican parties are being kind of
controlled and driven by the extreme
right and extreme left that's not who we
are as a country it's not how we became
a country and it's not how we Remain the
superpower of the world with the rest of
the country or the rest of the world
following us so I'm going to go out and
talk to people to find out what they
believe needs to be done they'll make
the decision not me or anybody else but
I want them to know that there's enough
of us in the middle that want to take
back our country our values who we are
how we became the country that we we are
and how we're going to be able to leave
a country that we're proud of to our
children and grandchildren right now
we're not on that trajectory we've got
to change well let me ask you then H how
do you reconcile people that want to
enforce our immigration laws versus
those that want open borders how do you
reconcile those that want energy
dominance and Independence versus those
that want an immediate change over to
Alternative Energy or quote green energy
I don't even think the technology exists
uh how do you reconcile those that want
to dismantle the police reimagine the
police versus those that want Law and
Order and Safety and Security I don't
see middle ground on those issues
Senator well the Democrats have been
pulled so far to the left and I think uh
Joe Biden has been pulled to the left I
know Joe Biden and he never has governed
that way he wasn't a Senator for 36
years on the extremes and I'm hoping he
comes back to the middle I really am but
the bottom line is is everything you
have just said is what most Americans
want we're not going to be extreme
dreams to the left we are going to have
energy security Sean we are producing
more energy today than ever before in
the history of our country no matter any
presence prior to this we are an
Administration we produce more but we've
had to force them to do it I worked with
my Republican colleagues and basically
trying to get energy security making
sure that we have the energy that we
need today to take care of oursel to be
secured basically helping our allies and
investing in the technology for the
energy of the future we can walk and
chew gum we're the United States of
America we got more Investments coming
to the country than ever before you
never hear the president speaking about
we spent 230 billion of the IRA to pay
down debt you never heard that we
basically it's energy security it's not
an environmental bill it's been great
for the environment too if we're able to
uh to basically mure these Technologies
but we're producing more gas more oil
4.6 billion barrels of oil this year 37
trillion cubic feet of gas though and
and we're important we're importing
because we have to we have to blend
because of the type of uh uh you know
systems let me let me ask you this
you're going to go on this tw- Monon
tour there has been a lot of talk about
the the No Labels party I I'll ask you
again gently I'm not pushing you hard no
problem um I I just want to know is if
you got enough feedback that you felt
there was an appetite for a third party
would you consider a run if you thought
it was not a spoiler run to use your
words Joe absolutely I think that every
American if you're in a position to help
your country and you don't come forward
when you think we're on a wrong
trajectory then you know shame on you I
would do whatever I can to help my
country and right now I think unless
we're able to bring the extremes back to
the middle and if the extremes don't
come to the middle make sure the middle
is able to
dominate that's where I'm I'm looking at
but basically no labels has always been
a group that's look for a balanced venue
you that we could bring Democrats and
Republicans that felt homeless I've been
there since 2010 I understand where
they're coming from uh I've been to West
Virginia I know the people of West
Virginia they're pretty conservative i i
i they like you they like you Sean I
like they like you buddy I like them I
appreciate it Senator thank you for
being with us we appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else